what's up I'm here right on time baby as
always every time right on time
that's me thank you are you guys aware
that I'm like that's the real question
ayyy ayyy ayyy
who's excited I'm [ __ ] pumped dude I
am so hype for this game that's 30 year
old man game come out I'm like this is
some weave [ __ ] this is some [ __ ] [ __ ]
this looks like legit [ __ ] I'm into it I
like samurais and I'm not afraid to say
it
they're [ __ ] cool yeah
pirates cringe ninjas cringe samurai
only epic [ __ ] epic we're gonna
teleport to a time when men can be men
in ghosts of Tsushima very epic they
have already like I noticed I just
started it up they have different game
types oh you can play it in like movie
mode like Japanese traditional movie
mode so cool I love that [ __ ] I ain't
gonna do that though man I picked the
Japanese with English subtitles very
cool
that's what we're doing it looks
beautiful this game looks so pretty love
it
I hope this game will take what last of
us try to do and just say you know what
we'll make it better you want to have
fun in a game we like fun I hope at
least let's see reviews have been kind
of mixed of this game so my expectations
are in between it's always good to never
get excited about things because then
you don't get disappointed but I look
forward to playing yeah I'm into
I'm looking forward to it I'm just
waiting a little bit for people to jump
in here making sure everything is
working well are my lip synced I have to
change the sink let me check that action
it just stopped then you don't get
disappointed yeah it looks fine to me
Mike looks a bit loud
I saw Japanese people breaking down the
game and they were like this is
incorrect it is made by Western
developer which is a bit random for a
game like this but why not
why not Joelle Japanese edition I'm so
excited
yeah can you guys see it I want to test
something before we start so if I go if
I say right I will go right just make
sure that's timed I can look at it right
let right let looks pretty good right I
think so here's you can't get tier 3
membership yeah I don't know why some
people can't upgrade so stupid try using
VPN Nord VPN that come / pewdiepie try
it make sure you clear your cache Ebro
it's a cash your cash I don't care no
one shouldn't care the real question is
whose mother flipping hype hype dang
pathetic it's perfect yeah yes yes hey
minister in oops Oh Kanagawa Tsushima no
Yuri
1000 Mashiro a game Oh Donna she me
Donna she meanie [ __ ] mas
nihongo HEDIS gomennasai let's freakin
do this yeah we start off in Tsushima
very ethnic I got what do you think I'm
gonna do
sorry I get so annoyed you just disrupt
everything so little egg we were getting
hyped and [ __ ] sorry I was a little
harsh there I apologize I regret what I
said when I was angry
yes
[Music]
Oh Mari
so you know what it imma meet Utah what
a cool summer I actually wear those
armors and I'm also confused because I
thought samurai was like independent
from each other that's what I know
goddamn well we had the higher ground no
problem
[Music]
why am i wearing headphones I can't even
hear a virgin
he's got Dark Souls armor yeah
told you oh [ __ ] dude
whoa hell yeah graphics looks [ __ ]
great day oh my god if we get to play
here [ __ ] yeah
hell yeah oh my god I get to slice
people oh [ __ ]
how did he be shooting this /big come on
you're again dead you're dead
it's what you get for messaging me on
PSN oh [ __ ] god damn it
whoa gee sweet you lady
Tina's like who the [ __ ] are you hell
yeah since I block a slice heart attack
what is this change stands
hell yeah those goddamn Mongols and
their [ __ ] Ewoks
Papo
[Music]
heart attack
[ __ ] yeah along how they just let you
play right away instead of crispy dish
to do this I could figure it out I'm an
adult [ __ ] got shield hell yeah
just a lob a Kurosawa mode let me try it
really quick
I don't even know who's good and bad now
[Music]
yes come at me bro I apply this
stickiness
y'all want sticky [ __ ] bring it so
[ __ ] cool I'll change the mode oh god
I love it so far show masking cutscene
show blood I can call horse heel and
then there's photo mode they just let
you jump straight into [ __ ] yeah
I did it yeah you're dead bro why not
stab him
who wouldn't touch you thank you oh
you're getting scared
can I call uragan no I can't do that now
this is 60
kögel the kid checkout schedule
thank you for the subtitle sir
[ __ ] they're goddamn Mongols shitty
Mongols
always a trick up their sleeves always
how's the volume of the gameplay and you
want to up or down no no
[Music]
oh geez huh Oh
that's a bro moment right there
[Music]
ah [ __ ]
what a real [ __ ] you want it up
let's try that I I read some of our
Genghis Khan it's such an interesting
story of betrayal and redemption and not
redemption BAE yeah
Marika I bought over he doesn't worry
Raimondo he played tuber simulator
[Music]
yaki Haram : he might still know ready
to solder are you worried Niko dark [ __ ]
now
spit
now damn we have our enemy god damn
I reported Genghis Khan back in eighth
grade and can say it was really
interesting it is a crazy story all
about revenge
Hey
[Music]
we're back baby and it's our quest for
revenge now mr. Genghis minge [ __ ] yeah
very dope so far very cool
[Music]
this is how I sleep
no I didn't pay the digital deluxe I'm
like [ __ ] that I don't want to do that
for someone worked hard to keep me alive
huh some good ol Lotus very tasty
more goodham all those [ __ ] Mongols
[Music]
but daughter Coco you cannot tear it off
so the moon'll not touchy let's get our
sword do not raise alarm of course
well well well let's go here
during the whole tweet your dog Brusco
quarry we got our armor back i still see
me but better than nothing dude it looks
awesome they're telling me to leave the
house all right
[Music]
it's not gonna be able to hide man just
once is rice you gotta respect that at
least never underestimate your enemy you
not
I think I Hasina say today yes Shh
it's Tsushima an island sorry about that
bro press r3 to crouch
that's a big boy I can't see us
thank God you can actually sneak faster
Tommy
suyodhana extra water very cool very
nice but why did you come out could I be
given you agree cause you to cuckoo you
say why you wear this made with the
English in mind first cuz the lip-sync
is pretty terrible was you yes how you
go we do not see more tougher what any
doctor when you eat song
[Music]
[Applause]
snake gang there's so oblivious Japanese
Abbey Jabby
oh nice got that on my face Oh God
you okay there girl
guess some games never change huh god I
had that crawling through it small space
segment otherwise yours you Shh
that's kind of cool
sorry bro
[Music]
let's cut new animal ha you mad
okay okay
[ __ ] excuse me what I can't see me I'm
on a ceiling that's the number one rule
of stealth dude we got some bento nice
that's how real samurai climb ladders
got some more suppliers [ __ ] she
died or a it played like the controls
are so much more smooth than last of us
it feels so liberating to play this you
can actually move around I guess I'll
look inside sold song just give him that
man if the door not right now who do you
know at all Boadicea Cory loves Sark how
you can oh ho - if so excuse me you know
Jose could touch that
so anime yeah humorous available was
here till cuckoo addicts
yo mama I answer you are Daniel mother
Sunoco guru
she's a man even our answer Nikki's Oh G
oh we get to practice now
hell yeah he doesn't even have a weapon
nevermind he's gonna hit us with that
thing isn't he goddamnit
alright so four quick attacks heavy
attack oh cool let's pull the leaves to
the wrong was you know Bonilla will
cruises it sarkar Eugenia you now it's
not too smitten you tap triangle to
break defense and stagger an enemy enemy
and then quick attack oh you're quick
going up the ring boy our salmon service
is a block I thought we were fighting
[Music]
yoosh resolve me to draw on your result
to heal and perform other special
abilities gain result by killing enemies
pairing attacks and using this kind of
like blood-borne if you keep momentum
you get more stuff is that it or I don't
know
sorry then it's me pretty
straightforward but I like then you'ii
come over
yeah Tsunade Muscat I mean you just
asked for a break as well no god there's
different enemy attack with nail they
eat a medium Astarte Jin you watch 2
katana could I be able to America as I
got a key message o.o Maturana
stood so cocky they miss you so I can
you go home to whom are you milk America
says ok we gotta win this now then how
do i lock on him then i'll start off a
grass him
did I win
that was easy I get to choose dinner car
a all the guys Bush you are kitty to
mama tick-tock gotta go that's right I
read a book recently that was really
interesting explaining the mindset of
how Japanese view the Emperor and their
obligations in life towards their family
it's really interesting
oh no Mama Lenin woman ah
oh my is Ashiya Donna Missoula orogeny
sky another a monogamous anova you be no
cheeto says suit all targets kill my
mother
no compassion
what's your more silly scene still
discussing what a tall kid so Memorial
Day Tommy no more honey not I never nada
what you don't booty talked about
sorting up mario luigi de and here we
are not it's fighting time [ __ ] yeah
what's the point of this game what's the
point of any game to have fun
[Music]
[Applause]
immerse yourself and forget the world
exists [ __ ] yeah
all right so this is spear guy well look
try and do some I'm eyebrow [ __ ] I
didn't know he could attack one that was
eight I was expecting more hello cat
doors I use them don't care yeah again
again let's go I can't possibly see us
we're behind the rock
our knees are covered
[Music]
what was my code [ __ ] I didn't mean to
not like take them by surprise
target the pulsing enemy and attack tip
cool hell yeah
those talks about 20 Christ oh yes
[Music]
are we in Kyoto I can't be right
are there many golden temples I thought
there was doesn't you know scary would
you would you in with least I know today
it's illegal
you show Nikhil okay I guess
[ __ ] incense did I die
oh [ __ ] I didn't pay attention to my
help at all already my bad
well this will be a long for the way
through then yeah run away cowards
[ __ ] I need to know how to dodge
otherwise I'm gonna be in trouble can
you [ __ ]
I think I'm playing on hard by the way
that's why I'm gang which one looks more
like er again
you look cute I like your little hair
thing oh you have it - I feel like white
horse is so generic yeah
entire iourney [ __ ] alright
it's the Ergun 3 then Sarah that's so
far feels good
no boots sorta cocky huh which one do I
like more car game wouldn't make sense
Connie yo mama young
cool target is
kaga yo yo yo dog and son
and we're off
you guys pick cockatoo cool I'm glad we
agreed on that then it's like 15-second
delay yeah ha ha that's the movie it's
the mama across
your filthy mom goes to all right now
we're just going straight on wait here
until I finish them okay
BRB a standoff when an approaching enemy
turn when approaching in enemy territory
you can challenge post to a stand up
once your enemy approaches hold triangle
as soon as they attack release to defeat
them in one strike
I was holding drangle Christ
[Music]
you mean it yes [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] yeah
hell yeah why is this game not forcing
you to kill dogs zero out of ten yes I
agree okay I'll change it to harden cuz
clearly I was [ __ ] lying
good thing I'm zero deaf anyway oh they
[ __ ] start with the spirit
yes she did oops my bad
listen I'm a slow learner but once I
learned trust me everydays Khan I want
to just look around and [ __ ]
it's where they keep their hands nailed
it
that's kind of cool so that gets charged
up by killing that's awesome
[ __ ] I thought I could time to stand up
I suck
don't touch me I'm trying out different
things
Sarah devs stop can't stop counting stop
counting
I'm trying different things that's why
nice sudha see I was trying to just
stand up I guess I can't do it
yeah shoot then you're dead
ha let's do it every day
oh [ __ ] she didn't mean bring it [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] them out
[Music]
we're shooting all of it that was
[ __ ] cool I blocked them in there
does she night no less you are
okay what's your toast get out can you
get that voice I need it [ __ ] your [ __ ]
[ __ ] filthy Mongols
we got the [ __ ] spare guys I hate
them all right here we go
bring it Spearman you nothing I'm in
trouble I'm in trouble
I'll deny I [ __ ] up I'm learning it's
a learning process
trust me change difficult shut up you're
dead stay that please I need to save my
uncle do you understand
do your thing
there are many it's not fair how didn't
I suck I [ __ ] sake
goddamnit maybe I should change baby
you're right
[ __ ] no never never change [ __ ] you [ __ ]
your ball name it's your fault we need a
new plan of attack what we need to do is
we need to utilize the elements of the
skies and we go this rock first yeah ah
eh [ __ ] you
[Music]
yeah [ __ ] you and your spear that's how
he's done mother god damn I hate the
spear told you my battery is low told me
bro I told you about the battery bro
[Music]
[ __ ] this is wrong cable hello I have
one right here
[Music]
sirrah Deaf's feels good man feels
really [ __ ] good to be in the top
player of this game online you're
watching the best gameplay on the mother
flippin planet bring it manga how does
dead feel like can't talk now can you
[ __ ]
dodging arrows before firing arrows
Mangal Archer will call out and signal
their allies to duck
what is duck in Mongolian miss me miss
me with an arrow [ __ ] oh you're going to
regret them ow
who's up there who [ __ ] shot me mate
you didn't know one god damn it I
thought for sure there would be someone
haha let it go climb climb we gotta
cross the bridge you goody
you must oh this is dangerous
you stand off time big stain of time
now Utah's awesome awesome
but if William
haha [ __ ] yeah bring it
[ __ ] they get you so quickly hey no pain
no gain
oh god I got to do all of that
alright maybe I shouldn't change that I
don't want to die that much yeah do that
again [ __ ] didn't think so [ __ ]
sir that's [ __ ] best gameplay on
YouTube [ __ ]
nice haircut
[ __ ] I'll do fast blocks and see if
that helps
yeah that's that's more effective
instead of just holding down block like
I was doing yeah
cult dude whatever you said
[ __ ] yeah come on Big Daddy bring it
ain't afraid you chubby [ __ ] she
told you
oh you look at the honey looks loke
Kanna cute
ah no I'm sorry no katachi tourism sekai
t-coils enemy Satan marina were ready to
insert a katana
slowly to Sakai and just don't look at
the lips and it's it's totally fine
this is one of those where you're
supposed to die
[ __ ] you now I heal it what I was right
it's one of those where you're supposed
to die which is why that on purpose it
was a tactical death no you can't just
kill me in front of my uncle no yeah I
told you this bridge is a bad idea
I thought I told them I told you about
the bridges bro I told them don't count
that as a death I didn't I
do you
cuz I'm
now
[Music]
sorry about that bad
sort of somehow this Oh No - same I do
no more longer what Styria would come
what I need to do you mean of kyster no
no no cut okay no no they feel oh poor
story they are my failure
what still yeah Catherina relativistic
laughing oh ha ha
Tori to marry me mama took the famous
Azula 1 go horn Inga
what's that could I find myself she
walks very awkwardly in an awkward pace
yeah look at this never been so hyped
for a funeral
[ __ ] yeah I'm walking in the club like
my playstation sounds like it's about to
explode
nice hairdo guess the Japanese are not
immune through baldness
[Music]
so that what I shouldn't say this gene
Sora demo buscar it's too though
but that's your cupboard
I mean he's not wrong Kumamoto tell me
you saw this you know
sorry not enough qualified a lot o mine
is you I also know how much you I'm not
touching you don't do
Cory would storm way
[Music]
Keith skin's fall in love then and then
yeah we haven't got an Anatomy intro yet
disappointing was you know even you
could have a you know Caillou
cool Genie luck honey what's new
[Music]
nihongo bros how is the translation is
it true or is it kind of awkward because
I know some shows just do it all wrong
so there's no point in me even trying to
I even notice some weird stuff that's
cool
he's got the YouTube rewind on it [ __ ]
yeah that's not a good sign actually
yes Japanese is such a difficult
language to translate we'll follow the
wind with the crabs I know this is what
the game is really about it's open world
and you follow the wind to kind of take
you places and you just explore and
because that's what I want from this
game look how gorgeous this is
I like how they just went overboard
where they
now well how about then ya know that
simulate kill what of Kyoto stahma why
not honey
that [ __ ] would usually do
we not your statem additional scrutiny
ma you fail me got a laptop video it's
seriously not a document how come
they're only wearing the armor on the
right shoulders because it's easier to
guard your left
hallelujah don't touch them Cudicini Oh
No student who cannot set up your color
label on my swatch this unit on would
scream
[Music]
grass time can't see us now thanks crash
you're the best hiding pampas grass with
Yuna hmm hmm we're hiding pampas grass
root unit this is the samurai way oh
there's my main I taught him well boy
you get water it go more gooey sticky
dough without skidding my day so well
huh not a turtle or d1 are you they were
mother I'll see you in we didn't want us
to you each course will see it
oh that's most of it
kudos to you do ye Anacortes Kariba see
modernity bond occasionally cotton it's
kinda serious you know become a dog this
is dark souls question mark blacksmith
preaching unless you're certainly doing
order the color I know I gotta know who
I'm gonna you know
[Music]
Kannada thought or dusky sounds like a
deal
[Music]
let's go here again nice - yes sir
I'm [ __ ] into it
[Music]
[ __ ] yeah
oh hell yeah sucker punch' be like now
we have the title yeah
[ __ ] yeah that's water [ __ ] that all
they spent a lot of time with it look
it's beautiful
goddamn I rode through here for some
reason so it is an island this is a tail
okay
Warriors code unit searching for her
brother a black kid named taka who has
been captured by the Mongols she's
checking on a lead near Keshi fishing we
may get a legend increase and focused
hearing or as your legend grows you will
learn powerful new techniques sweet what
about this tale of sensei Ishikawa and
you should have a tail one out of nine
sensei Ishikawa never joined our battle
against the Mongols had Komoda beach if
he's still alive I could use his skill I
think we should start with her what do
you guys think I'm also gonna we've been
playing for an hour I'm just gonna get
some snacks and I'll be right back so if
you want got a pee you got to do what
your thing five minutes and we'll we'll
meet here again automatic loss
openness let's go
alright ready go
yes just going to eat this pair really
quick mmm so juicy pear gang mmm damn
where's ol juicy [ __ ] yeah
that has a memory of some are [ __ ] I'll
turn it up
[Music]
sorry
hmm slurp slurp gang are you guys like
the game so far I love it
how do I like the pair so far I love it
too it's my fan that you can hear it's
not the ps4 let me write brighten up the
camera a little bit yeah
I look all green and [ __ ] strange color
so good
I ain't fasting today boys
I'm having all the snacks I want thank
you or Oh God Thank You rgn girl na
Samar Erin
he's like anyone said ASMR I'm here
all right these carb killers are so good
bagged out they're good for you though
21 gram protein 2 grams sugar that's
pretty good
they keep me breakouts though I don't
know what it is in them all right I'm
moment sir
hope you enjoy that little mukbang I
fast on days when I don't work out
because I don't need as much energy
that's why
okay understand do you understand I'll
[ __ ] where am I
yoosh ready to play more thank you for
waiting
I think it's been five minutes let's
flip and do this so what was the
consensus we learned focus hearing and
but he's kind of cooler though and we
get the bow yeah
so follow the guiding wind does he shoot
to reach the track the projective swipe
up we need to go across the river guess
we got a little ahead of ourself we're
collecting flowers and [ __ ] how do we
gallop yeah that's what I meant to do ya
know you're good no sorry
oh I press down l1 show me the way when
it's this way you didn't realize it was
alive until I left the room that's funny
whatever got here we got some you would
didn't realize you were in here ha ha ha
ha ha liberate Ogawa dojo
well [ __ ] yeah I'm gonna liberate the
[ __ ] out of this dojo I could call for a
standoff or I could just kill them let's
just Anna poor you're approaching me
[ __ ] don't ever come at me [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] are those are those dogs
I'm here to liberate from Mongol little
Schmitt the Mongol go bye-bye
they go bye-bye bye
I'm playing by the rules [ __ ]
you blind all right bring it then I
ain't afraid of no ghosts
oh he stuck behind the horse
[Music]
are the shooting arrows [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm
gonna die okay we're good yes come on
yes [ __ ] yeah that was awesome oh [ __ ]
there's dogs ah no they making me kill
dogs I'm so sorry
oh no I got a die from the added dogs
make the dog stop I'm out and for that
reason I'm out
I'm out I'm out I'm out I'm out I'm out
I'm out stop [ __ ] dogs
and during this [ __ ] don't look it
didn't happen on screen it didn't happen
on screen he's fine he's just sleeping I
put I gave him sleeping pills that's it
my man just got some sleeping pills you
ain't seen nothing all right
and damn what's with video game
developers and dogs [ __ ] there's too
many I can't make this you didn't see
[ __ ] my man that's right we'll take them
out you didn't see [ __ ] my dude forget
about it [ __ ] we got it we got it we got
a bad situation here
[ __ ] yeah Eddie - ow [ __ ] him almost
then Oh [ __ ] spare a guy scared me ha
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] all right
let's try that again
or actually maybe we should try and
focus on getting upgrades before we do a
big big epic things you know what I mean
chill
that's cool though I like that maybe we
should have got in with uragan come on
win why are we not getting closer mr.
Winn
Casas on a Monday did it it didn't steal
okay that's the village how do we get
there through here yep [ __ ] ain't huh
yo epic hey I miss the flower
yo we got hot springs baby that's the
bridge going dude
rumored location updated gather I'm
research related and stored in the
collection menu collect artifacts to
learn more about the Mongols research
are collected you collected are stored
in your satchel
okay so we can change our cool that's
very cool
and we need to asking the inn so pretty
and then bamboo goes in my thing
how you doing there [ __ ] bridges yeah
geronimoooo revolt a quorum is demo GT
cinema salute Christa moussaka Cora made
Amira arataura rqq cable that's casino
euros Kariba Ichigo Tommy she could hide
bamboo stain that's how y'all excuse me
definitely not nice I was too slow I hit
the wrong button
so then ten ten ten ten ten ten ten
yes my resolve has increased what does
that mean my mother Veronica Garcia
Gaetano disgust you are getting you a
cake or a B no mikata funding or Kublai
Khan Ithaca cake what are you I suppose
I must say he also does you need not
take oh das a diva
what as jolly
at bay
am I going farther away excuse me old
lady should we take some time and chill
in the hot springs it looks very comfy
so what's the button to just dismount
without jumping there we go god I have
some dignity you know
do you know commercial flower clock nice
soda it supplies [ __ ] should we
take the air again Jurgen you shield for
a mini-movie need to know sooner they
won a Hoyo cada vez yo meta equal to the
moon
they were simple nice glad we cleared
that up
is it up there
your guns asked for that shot I like
that comes nice to me logo can ocean on
your cushy diesel correct on this yeah
Lozano Tommy knew who could hear two
states alone octave
well I mean he'll in alright you're
gonna smell again I need you main we're
going up up got a rotten boss and wasp
net okay I grabbed it cannot [ __ ] with
it nope
[Music]
hidden spring for ash nicer
it's Zorro's voice who's that
sensei chicawa just goes insane abruzzo
let's check it out
[ __ ] oh they didn't you quarter what you
know what if the archer guy teach me you
no good at all yo Lee dude it's gonna be
a pain to wash up
you don't know it's from one piece no
way that's awesome
like I can't believe one piece is still
going it's so old isn't it what the [ __ ]
just became a sizes Creed out of nowhere
you're gonna make yard again shmurda
ghin just walk down I don't feel good
about this
return to the dojo why did I climb down
then for [ __ ] sake
are you serious
extra training oh and the hope I can do
this in real life
so I think that qualifies me to play
this game and no one else is thank you
just just go bro see I would have done
this way quicker honestly kind of cringe
bro guess I got a little ahead of myself
hunt will find him she nice to us she's
so low you
I'm collecting [ __ ] no big deal
I'm getting flowers and [ __ ] commodity
mercury mr. looker taught you that so
kunio tamura to follow through much
community turtle
so my everybody knows the Udo true
tsumuji Chico yo Kyoto not prejudiced
throw it on me no smoke in there what's
good for you show a lot this uni ship
once already know don't care pretty much
it
no you don't know cause you're the CRO
Oh Korea or denial
I hope we made the right choice
I'm going with this guy first shining
corn you're gone
sorry the huge snow boots
oh there's no no no you bozo marina
exactly dude
Tom oi whoa Nobuko good motive oh I saw
them too
just for the record on high when you
watched an author Scott soon annoyed
this is she gonna go puke stores in Vasa
didn't know they were pow-wow sign up
nice
bring it on bongos you're nothing but a
bunch of Baldy Bowl you Shh
don't think so [ __ ] let's get
the Archard gross I don't [ __ ] with you
[Music]
you want some get a haircut [ __ ] all
you need help
never mind what wait I'm coming bra
Loretta
oh no Seiko watch Oprah who did I shoot
so he was you gonna reward enough
like his shoulder pads route okay I
found this who mentor can I eat it this
guy knows a lot let me say a.k.a spa all
right what do you make her this mr.
Baldi oh my god so still to come they
[Music]
cure more on a book how'd you know about
Iran almost suppose fear is the mind
killer you know call your mother
we knew it straight do I see a commode
annually but now you - Arabic o so emo
Tony topic really know the market a
co-worker kid Amin on your khaki muffins
or Archie gonna wanna maybe me Thomas
Cuban on meet you Amy - no mean your
aura
what does that mean reload my sword us
sorry about that guys
that's how I walk in Sweden it's got
it's a pity pie bow nothing more painful
know what if there are none why
nah I remain your guru near optimal bro
easy oh [ __ ] oh oh that one my bad
it doesn't drop anything at all go and
see secure a little oh he wants me to
shoot this one I'm not paying attention
again I don't even drop it Oh Janie now
Jimmy must not 30pi ball bro hole no you
mean Oliver
yoky Amidala he's so commuting away
stood up Google do a night
moo-coo no pill you a huge coup that's
not very optimistic guy very epic all
this dough nobody ever you in
we pair another so now you could be a
you
mm-hmm well cos you did yeah
they were to shoot okay
yeah Asakusa I was in here with us hot
stuff oh she IMU de asobo you Camila
nany come on I wanna kiss on danke
all right what else can we do
barrows I bet they explode
[Music]
all right I like where this is going but
we're better take you he's good yeah
game came out today mommy
[Music]
yes we wait for the perfect time I'm
waiting for your signal bro any any time
now Danny ah [ __ ] it exploded right away
I just chilling anyone still alive oh
[ __ ]
[Music]
ahsha's headshot nailed it thank you
[ __ ]
and I get a [ __ ] headshot thank you
okay
self gang sneak gang climbing down the
thing gang what are there more barrels
that I didn't shoot there were yeah [ __ ]
main game oh that was cool
you take the you take the guy you take
the big guy see I did all the work there
the [ __ ] arrow guys where are they
[Music]
where are they okay we kill their leader
[ __ ] there's so many of them Jesus dude
he's got a clogged down get up
[ __ ]
I did fine you can count that wine
that's what I get for sucking peepee
they're like well [ __ ] was ain't stop
moving you shooting them
[Music]
okay I'm coming
[Applause]
[Music]
thought I could snipe them bro I can
strike the arrows that's kind of bad big
maybe not such a hands-on approach this
time
come on that was a headshot come on that
was a headshot I keep forgetting yet the
side dodged these guys that's what you
get [ __ ] god damn it
I suck I swear I dodge damn climb the
tower I calculated it okay let's do that
try not to die next time he died before
me so it doesn't count all right watch
this headshot I didn't let go god damn
it
nah hope oh you think you're safe
you think you're safe in your little
Smith oh yeah
alright let's do another approach I
meant to do that
it's called tactical jumping this time
just run like life service they have
like Club guys oh sorry about that bro
who who did this I was gonna shoot you
that's illegal
Oh
oh oh I'm out of arrows
[Music]
[ __ ] yes what the [ __ ] is that attack oh
god it did so much I'm out and for that
reason I'm out
it's called tactical fleeing it's not
retreating
I mean fleeing [ __ ] god damn it alright
I need I need uncle to help
alright part of the plan part of the
plan
part of the plan this is all part of the
plan what you want to do is you want to
get the supplies there and then what you
want to do it's going to go here here
and then up on the ceiling
you [ __ ] but oh you [ __ ] [ __ ]
god damnit small beeping all right so
Sierra that so far yeah alright watch
this watch this watch this
alright what's the [ __ ] nice look we
woke him up a blue bin thank you god
they're so annoying now he's there you
[ __ ] [ __ ] is there anyone else in
the towers where
I'm so dead I'm gonna die again I don't
know I like that it's a bit challenging
even though I suck at it I'm sorry who
is he shooting at this wall sucks I'd
rather not fight you
it's fine I have a lot of help I know
what I'm doing [ __ ]
please daughter no I'm getting worse
come on come on
easy watch this all right perfect let's
just pretend that we starting off from
here and I'm just like all right
headshot yeah and then I'm like and then
I'm like it shoots automatically after
you hold it too long and then I like
kill this guy for the hundredth time
all right now he's up in that [ __ ]
tower those old show yourself [ __ ]
[Music]
is that where we're supposed to go or is
that all right you show me the way then
we'll let papi do all the work
oh [ __ ] why am i walking into Hornets
[Music]
my dude they're dead oh there we have
someone is that someone yeah it is nice
I'll [ __ ] the sauce for keep forgetting
a triple attack ah ah keep dying
[ __ ] god [ __ ] dammit god dammit
okay from here on oh god I'm sorry
listen once I figure it out you all be
like whoa I feel so bad for being such
an [ __ ] he's so good now trust me
you're gonna regret it see that that's
an impossible move no one's ever done
that do you understand
you should be thanking me I meant to do
that
how the hell does he see everyone I
don't [ __ ] see them I see [ __ ] all
like how is he shooting it whatever lets
it get this little [ __ ] here he's
still there yet
[Music]
nice stay dead [ __ ] [ __ ] how do
I cancel an era here we go oh where the
hell yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] you in your mace
I'm so sick of it that's how it's done
suppliers [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah
easy this game easy you die in this game
or I cringe so much at people dying in
games oh I don't know how to beat these
guys
I like grind dad do it deal with him
yang don't forget
grandpa tanka
[Music]
now the move [ __ ] bro can I just always
hit him in the knee how they got more
arrows
oh nice amount of arrows here we go
y'all can't touch me [ __ ]
don't even try [ __ ] I got laters
[ __ ] oh you're gonna regret this
[ __ ] I slide through the roof
for no reason [ __ ] I get
surplice or [ __ ] perfect
playthrough happening live [ __ ]
these [ __ ] can't believe their
eyes a [ __ ] how he get so good
surprise [ __ ] brah his name
sounds like tomato in the moon what the
[ __ ] can in the chat why you know play
game huh
why you here I'm playing on SuperDuper
how r this difficulty okay I don't need
any more nu nudes cause
yeah sure I can stroll through the game
play it on the uz no problem where
Stoppa and challenge is fun at least for
me I know it probably is annoying for
you I'm sorry don't care dude that's a
sick shirt
what a waste makes me cry not sure what
we're looking for
sluggish that you do it's so funny like
learning Japanese one of the easiest way
to remember things is with Munich
Mew Nam ik's Manama --xs where you
pretend that it sounds like something or
you make up you make up something around
it like Saiga sheet or Saiga she means
like looking for and saw saw a guy in
Swedish means fairy tale so I always
imagined like fairy tale [ __ ] because
there was good looking for stuff and
that's how I remember it it's so idiotic
but it works so I looked up online what
other you Nam excite say that word
people were using and it's the weirdest
[ __ ] ever there was one oh well that's
how you open doors beauty pie style
there was one of four katakana where
they do move which looks like an arm
going inside a cow's [ __ ] someone
drew that on ironically and be like
alright now you'll remember it and it's
true sorry about that bro this cannon
here unseen for a [ __ ]
well end your pain don't worry bro
you're taking it Seto
no this 100-300 why she also know so
good you all night - wait nothing is
done
yeah I know I've died Sarah times in
this game yeah sure you are
big genius
[Music]
although simile Tomoyo still lives why
she no Erica don t know how there's can
still resort ordinary Tok Tok he got no
you only GUI water that ugly they were
cut it wasn't hamaji use this power well
so Shimazu you know navigation like
[ __ ] I don't want to be mild
we did it we got technique points oh my
god all right we want I feel like I need
this Perry at the last possible second
or evasion [ __ ] yell get evasion those
[ __ ] hammer dudes were hammering me
down man I have any weapon it's the bow
view upgrades not enough resources cool
what you're just chilling around mean my
horse no big deal
what a time to be alive huh
did I check it every hour for supplies I
hit a low key when I get supplies I'll
just have a little aftermath run-through
no big deal
hey you hope Hey
I'm gonna make sure I get all this stuff
definitely been in here have not been in
here though that was worth it that's how
you open doors [ __ ] better wrong the
other time cringe I didn't use any of
the barrels yeah I think I got it all
god dammit
all right you're gonna Morgan
brofist 69 timtam there you go alright
no wind cuz we don't have any Waypoint
look how much you can explore dude
god damn that's cool
undiscovered location should we discover
it
let's just go where the wind takes us
you know can la da de disco can him tie
what he for sure is you got them no wait
[Applause]
beautiful a we got flowers
going oh yeah and the birds if you
follow them they'll show you something
Thank You bird I would not have found
this on my own
that's how you dismantle yeah thanks for
nothing bird
we already saw this stinky bird can't
Isle de putte I doesn't somewhere again
hey guys hello
no I still know so no euro you army
needs get Amano needs car else has
character you are a famous I am a Timon
on attenuate Arriba wow so I know
Kirito was a way to also Russia no
honest USA USA to great yoruichi to
their startup you are hosting that scar
on you know NATO has it
Azam oh no Sokka I know Colin OS kakuni
mother you don't know more muscle we
finished watching Japan sings yesterday
it's out on Netflix now I really
recommend it it got terrible reviews
terrible and I don't understand why I
loved it a lot deeper themes than I
thought it would have
October yeah tada I love I love the guy
that was they just took from nevermind
cry-baby
the desire tight throw or something
applying okay myself the guy that looks
like my profile picture on YouTube
victim what I must go you know you know
somethin else you must seal worried you
go tough kata
I'll remember that thank you we have
traveler satire now I'm poor basically
now we can dye our armor cool
cool very cool but I won't do it I won't
waste my money right now got a little
camp here we got some [ __ ] so Japan
sings is based on an old Japanese
dystopian novel from like 1971 and they
obviously modernized it a lot
they have youtubers in it it's really
weird is a youtuber from Estonia they
have eSport in it we're gonna see be so
socio
alright what's cooking - I was hoping we
would kill some people but I guess
this'll do get the [ __ ] out of my [ __ ]
[ __ ] are there's a knife guys
while I didn't talk to him I don't need
a knife right now let's do it let's
liberate this [ __ ] [ __ ] we have a
bow now it should be easier right yeah I
can do it
but I thought it tied it all in together
I really like the freestyle rap thing
they did at the end they obviously took
reuse a lot from devil man crybaby but
it was fun I like that
I recommend they I would give it a 9
what the [ __ ] is this no I just
understand how you can like devil man
crybaby and not like Japan sinks are so
similar obviously doesn't like crybaby
turned out it ain't beautiful Japan
sings is still good it was good it was
great I enjoyed myself I don't care
alright liberation time what the [ __ ]
does filthy Mongols [ __ ] kill
kill kill no matter what
alright let's take out this [ __ ] which
I shoot him with the bow or should I
climb up and stab his peepee yeah excuse
me I meant to do that I meant to do that
hey [ __ ] he's dead [ __ ]
I'll ever shoot arrows I mean [ __ ] I
don't like that shape
[Music]
it's not a naked lady no she's just
wearing red hey mother [ __ ] spear man
[ __ ] it's fine it's part of the plan
[Music]
can't find me beat no don't blow the
horn
forbidden horn don't worry they'll never
find me [ __ ] day
[Music]
we're don't do that there's a lot of
them not gonna life
[Music]
I'm so scared I don't like the spare
guys yeah run away [ __ ]
run away Beach hahaha
gosh are you an arrow guy oh he shot me
with mid there
that's not very doors oh of you I hate
these guys
alright
you'll never find me who's shooting
who's shooting okay watch this surprise
just as planned
[Music]
[ __ ] I touched a little much nicer what
I do
I didn't do nothing the travelers attire
will pulse when artefacts nearby oh cool
bad ass
alright we're stuffing now they can't
see me I'm invisible
ah they got dogs I'm out
sorry doggie dog
[ __ ] attempt on smoke for them no damn
it it's so close I'm not winning bad
I'm not winning [ __ ] not that big
there's me one more Sashi mama banner no
problem the race is speaking sorry
[Music]
yeah who wants to face me first you
I got iron reflexes I run that makes no
sense to an iron be slow surprise a [ __ ]
don't tell don't tattle tale
alright the dogs are so dead
I'm sick of the dogs I don't even care
anymore
I'm sorry dog but you [ __ ] bit me
last time and you killed me the look
away livestream thank you it wasn't me I
swear I didn't do nothing
you're free you're free from the Mongols
hey you got some supplies thank you
[Music]
you're free
oh you got supplies in here thank you
you're welcome
give me your supplies yes all right
that's good man I'm a good I'm a good
guy watch this mother oh god what
happened
Boosh how's your cranium ah perfect he's
on the bed homies just chilling all
right where's that last banner oh we got
arrows sweet more arrows here there's
someone up there
no [ __ ] I need to understand how I
[Music]
cancel it must be in here that's how you
open doors keep telling you guys
[Music]
we haven't checked in here
nice last one we got it destroy the
black powder
cash cash hey run oh hello
okay alright
it's boom-boom time oh [ __ ] a bit run
[ __ ] nailed it
yes
oh it's boss time oh god no oh dude he
looks so cool compared to me
[ __ ] nope you're approaching me please
don't huh no I'll shoot an arrow right
in his eye
watch this click click
ah [ __ ] you
[Music]
I dine
[ __ ] he's tough
I mean I didn't die look away two
seconds it's porn don't look
[Music]
[ __ ] I suck that was embarrassing
that's right I can do it I can do it I
can do no problem
[Music]
[ __ ] oh god it's so hard to towel nice
you gonna get a beach
[Music]
ah God
[ __ ] dog guy that's not even
the name dog guard dickyvicky
[Music]
I know your moose at
Oh
[ __ ]
there it is there it is ultimate damage
easy totally a dog er easy oh god oh god
I'm dead again it's fine I can do this I
can do this easy [ __ ] don't kill me
please talk out dog guy I didn't kill
your dog
I got to punish him more
[Music]
come on dog gang yes bring it dog Gary
[ __ ]
dogger don't [ __ ] around dude
[ __ ] I can do it I can do it I can I can
back into
[Music]
yes socket dog a sock a dog r0 - that's
how it's done
suck it up gang
perfect zero there's no damage taken
feels good to be the best look happy
people live here now
[Music]
look how happy they are so happy smut be
first try feels good being this good I'm
chilling with Jurgen mud-bogging in the
hood has Ken left us sayonara Ken son
thank you for visiting Oh
Iren thank you we [ __ ]
liberated this year
y'all don't sit on the floor yeah you
better be brushing brush more more MORE
yeah you better be brushing
so there's a we can fast drive later if
we want merchants with seven new gear I
think we should do this now
so I'll track it and we'll go it feels
good
yes yes yes yes yes I love this game
it's very fun 420 bro Eugene already
died first second you join is this Kashi
nope
oh wow oh oh guys let's fight [ __ ] I
didn't mean to come here Baldy [ __ ] you
you scared you should be [ __ ]
how does that feel like [ __ ] yeah
I'll liberate left and right these
[ __ ]
they run in hi where are they show
yourself
what the [ __ ] was that sound yeah I
meant to do that
I was not climbing the lighter sucka
Sekai katana grade nice hello you're
gonna die if you go there trust me I
can't [ __ ] see him thank you anyone
else all my controllers vibrating
because I'm near an artifact I can feel
it I can feel the controller rumbling
back again it's still rumbling can't
tell if I'm getting closer or not I saw
some stuff where you can enter the
ground no it's nice Iren why am I here
nobody knows
[Music]
apparently there's a thing where you're
only supposed to sit at certain areas of
the what is it called
tonkatsu like the floor because samurais
would stab you through the floor or on
certain parts I don't know [ __ ] what I
go down here
[Music]
there is something nearby cuz my
controller shaky-shaky must be on the
second floor what the [ __ ] are these
people here how does that feel it was
good you know oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
oh this guy's huge student oh God
[Music]
excuse me can I just find a better angle
to fight you in thinking oh you're not
so strong I've learned the water stains
oh yeah the what their stance I've been
waiting for that the famous water stands
what to go bla bla different stances
highly effective against shield how do I
change names shield the breaker a
let's do that cool
cool cool this game is easy dude Sarah
that's dude
you hold r2 to change them and then
press Korean water stands now what there
stands I fight for water shape and then
I hold X to change today Oh got it
what third stands out where's the
artifact it has to be here no no no no
crawl back thank you how do I get out
new ghost excuse me what kunai oh cool
l + r1 [ __ ] yeah what their stands [ __ ]
yeah what's up girl
what's up Edgar alright we found the
second floor there's something here I
know it trust me guys
mr. dashi
oh we got it sweet
cool consider yourself liberal liberal
later
liberal later is it liberating yes it is
alright let's go on the quest horse
horse
mrs. no standard io nice reload the
stands I'm trying guys thank you
what the [ __ ] was I to me
we're looking for you now
[ __ ] you know what did I just
do
oh it's the kunai oh yeah let's do it
I hate him they can't see me I Ahura dr.
mo Koga horotec are coming in MacArthur
hace casi una de esta todo more skies
danny kanata no idiotic Akane yeah I
ordered the kita bersama awoken
I can read that
okay so we're going somewhere else oh no
gee all explore there's more in the
future
supplies thank you
we have a Japanese wife for guys this is
busan Arabic on Zhu Joe set over you in
your at all Bogota I meant to do that I
meant to do that
it's an old samurai trick you guys
wouldn't understand
we're going up all the way the mountain
god damn it's getting morning that's so
cool
- feeding method
are you guys liking the game I think
it's so cool I mean I gotta grab that
Bush bamboo bush where we're supposed to
go down here [ __ ] whoa you're gonna mess
around and [ __ ] with nobody so pretty
sorry is it here oh here it is fight
though
knock out the skin okay okay we're let's
lay out the plan see those we click them
and see those I'm willing to take that
risk I'm afraid so Meno Coveney scheme
ilaria
no God it's you know becoming you know
become a secret a one-nighter on it
Maruti Alto de Wanda Morinaga we Samurai
Oh Cosmo Castellanos about Tito scratchy
pushing along with she's me see you
whatever Omar a total money key Omar in
Otellini meal still cuz they will not
sue here you are not many energy of data
not today thank mo ya never listen to
woman never understand what was you feel
free to call me on that and I definitely
meant that in every way
[Music]
your sauce already tight
so yeah could I cannot a mother mother
guess we're waiting oh [ __ ] 150 hi Peter
Pyle also I'm from Australia can i get a
shout out of course
shout out through the story Latorre us
from australian very epic what is that
in real money Australian dollars what a
machine Okanagan is so cool
what the [ __ ] are you doing
synchronized drinking open
splish-splash-splosh
we grabbed a bamboo
excuse me total
this guy looks tough
hey Loretta uber cool so we don't use
our dad's sword when we are fighting
dishonorably I can't believe you I
subscribe to carbon citizens on YouTube
Lo and say what are you smoking we'll be
talking about
there were supplies back there but
assassinate so I watch some gameplay
trailer of this and it seems like
there's two different ways to play like
when Jesus Christ dude you either play
like a samurai or you play like this
stealthy ninja Kanna type that just [ __ ]
abouts and throw fireworks and [ __ ] like
that
good time to have a flashback hey come
on I'll say this bad stuff stay
come on the way it's a nice tiramisu yes
you've got almost a night
[Music]
that's very bright
where is this [ __ ] well you were
a big cook all that power must know I'm
getting close there I can smell it it
smells like Cancun Tomei what does me
cause I think what I say well my job
anymore where is C II must ah yah
these Tillery almost hit him he's
already dead means I cannot keys no
other yah okay yukata yours help she's
tall wooden you know you take up quite
early on yes or not you're not you're
not cinema
samurai our real site so expire before
woman chili
you think damn I'm a lesson for a little
boy we did at 69k [ __ ] yeah thanks guys
no more like stuff must keep it at that
I do miss ooh nah circuit Kaku no motive
Serena's some red nose not
20 joules it shoosh this ring whole new
meaning to what we're doing now if it
goes over you got to remove your like do
your part now it went over it did remove
likes remove likes quick you went too
far never go too far
chuckles a muscle it's gotta look in
here you go
oh god poisonous my senses
focus hearing pressed use revealing
nearby enemy position as well my dude
you're dead my dude you're dead
[Music]
this guy's like let's check out the pork
looking good at least he died on a happy
note this guy is like I'll just stay
here forever
I meant to do that [ __ ] you scared me
[ __ ] feels good man well we're back at
69 good job guys proud of you
damn you did it I'm sorry for being so
rough on you guys you were back at 70
what the [ __ ] is well we're back in 69
okay good good
bye glanced over and I see 70 or 68
there will be punishment severe
punishment didn't someone's seeing me I
didn't [ __ ] that really hurt dude this
guy won't die
thank you [ __ ] water stains I don't
want that sheet with stone stains water
stains bed stains not many people know
how to master the bed 17 [ __ ]
apologize stop it hello how are you lime
hello
she [ __ ] teleported their bonus you
are singing a photograph look at victim
see Madonna likes comedy I'm missing out
some techniques from the skill menu I'll
check it out in a sec Thank You mr.
Netherland do do you ever do that's what
I'll call the you do to my friend
joseline joseline hi hi I'm donating to
Yemen from last month i'm done i and i
wouldnt decided this month yeah takes a
while to process all the payment as [ __ ]
how can we look the Noda kogo though
using a guy's the critical mass even i
yo got a [ __ ] off screen so they
cut off would you little dinner Canella
don't know good at the 7 it's got a
gorilla jameson Otto study this more
dramatic refer to the muddy copy
automatically the lab st. game
why are we at 70 K Lankes explain this
our Qaeda so go there what you now could
ya know got the data machine so no photo
no slick you lost Ramadi
that's the big boy Palace Carosi
budino you dollar
we were mother eatables oh gee well
that's a gamete using Buddha brothers
Cacnea Yahoo Sita
subito - ox t or emo chick he meets girl
Sakuya he's joking many Tata kala
why she Mumma can we get viewers to 69
as well and then likes at 69 that'd be
epic
71 oh my god I don't ask for much
okay
now you see ok so don't care right now
there's a musician in azam azam oh he's
given people hope by receiving the tale
of Todd IOT and his mythic armor and we
can get his armor we can track that
trade tale oh that's so fun
okay so we can perfect Perry's recover
small amount of health pairing on an
unblockable attack from moguls oh that's
good we should get that
[Music]
nice three-kilometer maybe we shouldn't
there's a fox then where you guys see a
fox area
what's up kitsune and saw let's follow
him I almost said smen bank to show me
the way show me the way bank song he
wants to show me something what the hell
wait terrier again this is just like
Minecraft
all what the [ __ ] dude splish Splash
through the waterfall no I thought for
sure we could go through the water boy
ah
nope
where do you go is that it that that
there
and the whole yeah I think it's just
there we jump across maybe no it looks
dangerous
here we go
thank you banked all that's so cute
let's honor the bank other you are thank
you bein bend knee bend even tax on farm
and then I've unlocked a new charm slot
begged us to return to bless this
playthrough none sweet epic every should
find some charms
oh it's gonna poop out some gold oh that
was awesome
don't be scared
so we're planning to go all the way
there apparently
maybe we shouldn't let's let's take this
on the way instead or what we could do
now we should do that let's do that
let's just see what we find on the way
or can we
quake travel like yeah we could do that
save us some time so it was worth it
going through the effort of taking that
place
got some enemies
we could hunt Jesus Christ shoot him in
the heart
nailed it he's [ __ ] indestructible
[Music]
don't hurt your gun you [ __ ] [ __ ]
you die for this uragan I'm sorry there
I grabbed it
you can run but you can't [ __ ] god damn
it you Shh what's that sound we're done
without me down with that
so cool so cool very nice this game
we're here we go
[ __ ] then here main ah [ __ ] vodka on
Okinawa cheap taco no Gino toe
oh that's keno vulnerable gonna cover
Kumamoto Stanko dango dango dango guys
okay
[Music]
did it it did it did hey Korra's a lr1
towards enemy to throw tonight good
night good night I'm out of Kenai I can
do that to supplies
[ __ ] out west
you know become on the world Modine you
get on oh my oh sure you check good
stability
oh where are the stables
I don't know
their wing will show me [ __ ]
they took the arrogance they'll pay for
this search I gotta search the stables
well my bad game I really got to go off
there's a grenade launcher in this
building
[ __ ] yeah thank you now the tracks are
obvious follow the footprints oh yeah oh
yeah Phyllis dialog mission is in
English not Japanese that's why it looks
terrible yeah I figured that out thanks
for letting me know them
are the tracks going this way return to
the footprints
what the [ __ ] did why there's a light oh
[ __ ] yeah imagine this game has lights a
verse every [ __ ] funny
mi [ __ ] stupid
oh thanks game I guess I am
Bombo but um I know how to do that
not a problem know that you can't you'll
kill you again they'll pay for this good
things you can't aim oh I thought you
had blue hair that was the anime for a
second Jesus the old
what do she-demon has enemy not a--not
attracted Estella which is you Thank You
December I didn't see you thank you
- you must be muscle
what does you always you thought your
otaku
stop singing client it I don't want to
make me room Monica trainee kakuta
normal samurai oh nothing
you don't worry Donna so you okay now
truly communal shimano pretty well are
you meet a lie
what that's more Naoko Cerreta wanna
know he tell me a story must wanna see
Madison there are more see what about
Hatano singie Matheny
okay I recently got into anime again
it's super fun
I'm watching steins gate right now it's
super good very nice I really want to
see the monogatari series but I'm
debating if I should read the novel's
first some light novel readings
on any caption agostina each you know
Rita son I got a model you know you tell
her what you're gonna me now the coconu
meter thanks sir
we're honoring and [ __ ] press r2 to
honor not not to life Lagoon was a great
enemy code yes as well there's so many
way I feel like I'm too old to watch the
I also saw an Ohana and it was good
don't get me wrong but I'm like I'm too
old for this I sure I would have loved
that if I was like a teenager or some
[ __ ] again I would but not go into the
golden Tim [ __ ] yeah okay boys 13
okasada tour
there is this video on YouTube where
they asked Japanese people over clarity
if they watch anime and everyone's like
what they fail
oh no she studied it I think just like
this shown in John rrah in general I'm
like I'm too old for this
if it says shown an adventure I'm like
now I've seen them all I'm sure it's
great I'm not doubting you science game
seems different that's why I like it
even though I don't know I'm so I'm
again so tired of all the cutesy female
main protagonists that are just like
really supposed to be cute speak in a
high-pitched voice and act really dumb
it's like okay I get it just gets really
annoying
I get it they're cute and [ __ ] I get it
but I'm married there's a [ __ ] up so I
don't know why Tommy no Toscanini Roboto
she don't need to diss your wife though
by the way women almost wanna imagine
hiding at a tofu so much do you know
sugan to you another kid are your Hideo
Hodge this night Tommy oh no he's got a
lot of sweeping today my god these
leaves are relentless
I should watch it Gintama I've seen that
being high rated forever
I heard it's funny
hello muffled oh no not sky de honest
you know that you know your oh you know
still little cheetah Coyotes pop them
idealist let's get some [ __ ] samurais
[ __ ] yeah [ __ ] yeah yeah Jameson I could
oh god Ava it to them when I see my show
so no sigh so was i you're much good as
I don't got to tell Scott yeah I'm seven
that it says shown and [ __ ] I'm sure you
love it but I've seen them all you don't
understand I've seen every single shown
linen [ __ ] could ever afford it
otherwise oh damn that looks so much
cooler
[ __ ] all right let's get some
[ __ ] little red monster there
manga and everyone keeps from
recommending the anime and I'm like you
know that theta so notoriety she owned a
monster kono unit Odin Akiva a notary ot
dokoni is an actor critically time
Indies pouring out in you I heard the
non sagas renegade say so Sahara no man
I'm gonna just watch probably gonna
watch steins gate first and then I'm
gonna watch monogatari series what a
senior cotton on Okinawa coterminous she
taught us good so resonates she gonna
know the seal guys about so there what
I've seen a race it was fine it wasn't
that good don't care let's upgrade our
Sakai
there's like no difference oh my god she
much time
all right where is this sweeping ass
[ __ ]
hello sugiko Toyota Sequoia Thomas Oh
son Roy non-nude saku-dono correct
photos did our brothers can work at an
authority Okinawan rescinded
he really does soda we told you yet
approached diatryma tyranny
Kanaka Durga so my well it's too many so
much the story Monsieur Masako salmon
are a baroque under cannot era muy macho
what a face demo tourism may so Mike
sorry Tamika no helping me
no kinesin its carapace my must quarry
mother it's mono year motherboard your
corpse tawny da cunha
mor e muster yeah no how did you cannot
see Ohana do to us is it tough to
motivate escaping much sweets all summer
I need some [ __ ] action baby come on
Rumour location I can get linen I need
linen we're going to the linen what some
anime for boomers I don't want things to
be too serious but I'm just sick of all
the teenage shape
I thought a race was so weird like he
was the only one that had this power so
we could see the stories about this guy
that can see the future was that it I
don't really remember you can tell when
something bad is gonna happen
and you can also travel through time and
he tries to stop this little girl from
his childhood memory that gets kidnapped
or abducted and killed he's the only one
with the power it's so unexplained
I don't like that sheet if I just felt
like I had more depth to it and they
were just IRA it's done that it was fine
okay I'm saying it was a fine inma I
just didn't love me
same without Ahana even though I did
like I know how no more now haikyuu
that's some good anime [ __ ] that's some
real boomer [ __ ] yeah summarize
Shambhala is awesome let's follow it
[ __ ] I lost track of it
no I see you I see you excuse me I'm
busy I'm following a [ __ ] now I was busy
I was following the burn god damn
it's the bird gone totally silent noise
Dada
why goddamnit
I got a rescue his puppy now [ __ ] I
don't [ __ ] care
Finland saw the Viking enemy well that's
kind of a thing
all right show your peepee let's do this
this never gets old
don't think so [ __ ] who's next
oh [ __ ] the [ __ ] camera analyst
[ __ ] me over big time here what the
hell I can't see anything
what a mess I blame the camera angles
there the [ __ ] happened I thought it was
the other guy for a second doesn't count
if it's the camera angles fault everyone
knows this I didn't I wouldn't see it on
camera we didn't actually see it so okay
let's do that again but less [ __ ]
Yeah right
[Music]
where's the arrow guy Hey
Oh
now he shot his friend um alright one
[ __ ] I was like do you want some taste
of your own medicine keep forgetting I
had the cone ice more do they kill you
monster Inc is a good enemy true you're
not wrong what you gonna do
signs for the family we got it over here
nah that's a classic rookie mistake
yeah I never saw Elaine I watched your
first episode and I'm like this is weird
hey by the way your your son did
yeah for the coolies so again oh that's
my kind of [ __ ] I say we're already dead
on my way more Sheen dirty no shield
when you sitting up when I see more walk
when you're away
she told us good theory stuff famous
sorry about that bro
I did experience some so you know it
came for good use my main and we got
some [ __ ] linen man [ __ ] yeah
we got linen way they can't song man
then Anna let's get some more linen I
want the [ __ ] linen give me the lay
ninja
can you again do this come on jump [ __ ]
come on [ __ ] [ __ ] boy jump thank you
gain that linen bra
I'm all about that linen shape Oh a bird
nice let's follow it
show me what do you got ah [ __ ] ah
[ __ ] [ __ ] that's a big [ __ ] [ __ ]
right there
what's happening here guys
hey you hit the uragan you die painful
death out you die a thousand deaths
how do we get up there hot we can climb
[Music]
in case you're new on the live stream or
video we're a Sarah deft playthrough I'm
a professional ghost of Tsushima player
it's no big deal so we're following this
bird he's gonna show us epic treasure
it's whatever
look at that hot spring flip yeah
now we raced parasite sucks I agree a
finally we get some ass I was waiting
for it I reflect on my father yes I know
Houston I would push you boy increase my
health see meditating is good guys it
increases your health do it messes are
cool
that's why samurais are so awesome it's
not just about killing obviously it's
epic but it's also about the softness
they can find like poems written in and
they were they were read there were
write poems before battle some people
would find them in if they passed away
they'll find it inside their head or not
ahead now what am I trying to say they
will leave the poems in there and helmet
some people find them so they had
written this poem before battle that's
badass
and there's this general attitude that
you should spend as much time doing more
your things as you do
I guess calm things having that balance
that's what makes it interesting it's
cool it's cool samurais are cool say it
so yeah I read a sword and Kristen thiis
iam I keep forgetting how you say that
word but it was written by an
anthropologist American anthropologists
during World War two and her job was to
basically try and understand what would
happen if the Americans won the war and
how Japanese people would react I think
that that was the so she started
obviously as a foreigner and outside of
Japan so it's not very accurate but it's
still really interesting let's chill for
some dinner
and they were they were explaining in
the book how the Japanese mindset was
was - during world war two was to fight
until the very last man or person able
to fight they have this dead-set mindset
to just keep fighting and then after the
war it was very strange for Americans to
be greeted by the Japanese and they were
greeted in such a positive and nice well
way going from being deadly as I am
talking about the dialogue I just had a
bath I'm good
and after the war even there were so
dead-set to fight up there until the
last man they completely changed and
Americans were so completely perplexed
by it the fact that they were so
welcoming to the American soldiers and
that's such a unique thing to the
Japanese of being able to change their
mindset and the reason behind that was
because of the orders of the Emperor as
far as I understand I don't know how
accurate that means but so first the
Emperor had ordered people to yeah we're
gonna fight until the last man and
people honored that obviously some
people were against it as well but and
then when the Emperor said okay now it's
time for peace people wanted to excel in
being peaceful and that's why the people
were all the sudden so welcoming to jump
to the Americans after the war because
they wanted to live up to the Emperor
it's interesting I think that's so
unique to Japan that mines 10
apparently back in the day they used to
have like obligations so you have
obligations to fulfill to your Emperor
and there's some or it's almost like
you're owed someone something and some
cannot never be repaid but some can and
they compared to stark circles to be
fulfilled I don't think it's really
accurate to say that but in general what
the book said at least is that Japanese
don't have it they don't look at good
and evil the same way as we're used to
with virtues it's rather how you your
actions are more based on the things
that you owe and how you fulfill them so
you owe your Emperor you own your family
and there's obligations that come to
that and then there's stories around
where samurai had to disobey their
obligations
I think it's called kink or something no
wait that's not it this bank
confront the impostor nice was I saying
with the what was called the story of
the 47 samurai or Ronin I'm sure you
heard about it it's so famous let's
confront this guy first and I'll talk
about it they made movies out of it I'm
sure people know about it whoa that
glitch did you see that that
[ __ ] anybody like him find him I
don't remember exactly what this story
was but it was that there were these 47
samurai and their leader was dishonored
so he killed someone that was part of
the not the Emperor but a Shogun or
whatever it's called [ __ ] I don't
remember so well read into it it was
good this was a the Keanu Reeves movie
was 47 Ronin no way but in the example
of it is that they were in this state
where they had to obviously avenge their
master which they owe him but they also
can't go against the Shogun wishes
against their moral code or whatever so
to avenge their master they they went
into so such extinct lengths to trying
to avenge him because it would be to
obviously if they just try and kill him
right away so a lot of them sold their
wives to pretend like they didn't care
about it and became degenerate and did
all these horrible things everywhere
they got exiled from their family just
to pretend like they didn't care about
getting
and then finally when the right time
came they obviously got it and but by
avenging their master they had
dishonored their fulfillment to the
Shogun or whatever it's called so that's
why afterwards they committed seppuku or
harakiri afterwards and it's used as an
example of sometimes those fulfillments
or whatever you have obligations are
collide with each other and it leads you
to do things that don't make sense
it's hard to understand that it's hard
to understand as a foreigner living in
such a different time these concepts
that seem so insane that you would first
of all kill yourself with a sword
because of your master and all these
things you really think about it seems
like why I would never do that
what the [ __ ] such a different mindset
such a different way of living
I think I should end the livestream here
I've been going on for too long okay so
some write that I got exiled like or
owning that's good to know I was
confused by then um thank you for
joining this livestream I love this game
it's so fun I hope you guys had fun too
watching the pro the master the one and
only we'll check you out more next time
you just joined well ain't that a thing
[ __ ] I'm so hot how long three hours 40
minutes not bad in that band not bang
alright see you guys next time take care
brofist thanks for joining appreciate
you guys thanks for all the members
thanks for all the subs it's fun I love
this [ __ ] I love it so awesome see ya
and it's all awkward is like if I end it
now the last things I said won't be
shown so I'm just gonna try